bye
there are there were several London of
course instituted some years ago perhaps
five or six years ago now congestion
charging to enter the center city of
London they have their their recordin
and you pay actually quite substantially
to drive into London and that has had an
effect on the congestion levels that
have existed and has had an effect on
the share of travellers that are using
public transportation so London was the
first major city in in in the in the
developed world if one excludes
Singapore which has been at this for
30-something years but it is in a
different kind of political environment
than liberal democracy such as London so
London can be a model for for the large
cities in for example North America
there are other cities in Scandinavia
that have had good luck with these kinds
of approaches a more informed more
informed thinking about land use less
cod dependent living patterns and
congestion charging to allow the system
to reach some kind of equilibration to
allow people to pay less for highway use
as a function of when they choose to use
it and therefore create less of a need
of a building of traditional
infrastructure so there are in fact
examples going forward many of those
cities of course I speak of London and
Fran and Paris many of these cities of
course would develop before the era of
the automobile and if you look in fact
in the United States you look at New
York and Boston and Philadelphia these
were cities that were largely in place
before the automobile became such an
extraordinary
factor within our transportation
enterprise so you look at those cities
with very well-developed public
transportation and you compare them with
Phoenix Phoenix in Los Angeles that grew
up largely in the era when automobiles
were already quite common and you see a
very different kind of pattern so it's
going to be a long pole to see if we can
make some of these changes but if one
thinks in a creative way technologically
if one thinks about transportation as a
complex system and understanding it in
that way if one thinks about different
institutional structures for managing
the transportation enterprise that is
more sensitive to the need of the myriad
stakeholders the transportation has I
think we can make good progress on all
three dimensions of sustainability I
think we can continue to develop
economically I think we can create a
system in which we are much more a
steward of the environment and perhaps
we've been and I think we can do
something from a social equity point of
view to make sure that the environmental
impacts our shared equitably and the
economic development benefits are shared
equitably as well